in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast I'm your host
David Stone we have a very special guest
here we got that og dancer yeah I'm
saying we got [ __ ] band BTEC chung
daeun was good you know that any time
people call me oh gee I mean I guess I'm
supposed to you know take that as a
compliment old guy no man it means that
you have been around the block in your
oldest [ __ ] I don't mind down though I'm
down you know it's like when people say
like oh you're [ __ ] uncle David or
whatever you give advice I actually like
that [ __ ] I actually don't want to hold
on to my youth at all [ __ ] my youth like
I I think being a young person sucks I
kid you not
yeah like everybody has this thing like
when they hit 30 they go oh [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] thirty years old or even
sometimes when they hit 40 like I'm 40
years old I could give a [ __ ] less like
I actually like getting older yeah
because when I see young people I like
smell number-one insecurity I smell
people who have no idea what they're
doing not every young person but I cuz I
see myself in a lot of this you know and
I don't like that so when I when as I
get older I get happier because
especially when you get older you could
give a [ __ ] less about with somebody
things yes sure when you're young all
you do is think about what somebody else
thinks about you specifically for me
what I figured out and what I'm learning
right now and I think I talked about
this before was I'm learning to white
light now which I which I didn't know I
didn't know that I didn't I didn't do
very well so it's because I'm very
straightforward it's like for example
it's wedding season so yeah I had a
conversation with my girlfriend and she
goes you know you should probably learn
how to white lie better I was like what
do you mean I was like I don't like
lying she goes I know you don't like
lying but she goes that's probably half
the reasons why we argue because you
don't know how when not to speak your
mind I was like what do you mean I was
like for example it's wedding season
somebody hits you up and even if you're
not that close to them they go hey I
would love for you to be in my wedding
what you should say if you can't go or
you don't want to go as hey
congratulations I'm glad that you're
getting married but I'm probably gonna
be busy you know thank you for the
invite right but what comes out of my
mouth is I'm good thanks man I don't
know what made you think we
that close but I'm good man you have a
good one and she goes well why'd you say
that I was like because that's on that's
the truth she was get but they don't
need to hear that and like you could
just say you know you're busy right
right right I get it man I get it it is
wedding season though man like yes crazy
I just saw you said well Ellen was on
your show yeah weeks ago yeah she I saw
her at a wedding she was the maid of
honor she did great but like you know
when she came on our pod she was talking
about how it's just stressful being a
maid of honor man it's a lot of
responsibility and money that goes into
this bro I just so I'm not trying to out
anybody but I lost homey a close Obie of
mine recently got married and I love the
guy to death I've known him forever and
he asked me to be a groomsman of course
bro like yeah like you know no question
so we did it and so there's like you
know the bachelor party to the renting
the tuxes to the hotel blocks to the and
I just like wait so none of this you're
providing like this is all coming out of
my pocket and I'm paying for you to okay
so I'm just like I got a I gotta be
careful who I agree to be a part of like
their their wedding party man cuz that's
that's an investment that's the crazy
thing right so somebody says okay I want
you to be my groomsmen or best man and
then you think it's an honor
no that's a [ __ ] bird yes bro so when
I so some of my friends know me so well
like I was a groomsman for what for -
for two weddings so far like last year
right when they ask me what they prep
what they said right after was so funny
they go hey I would love for you to be a
groomsman trust me you don't have to do
absolutely anything he's got to show up
yeah cuz you [ __ ] know me cuz if you
knew that if you were gonna tell me I
had responsibilities they heard you ride
the bat no no thank you
look you have a good one yeah that's a
real friend they know you yeah because
even for my wedding if I have a best man
or whatever i'ma tell them you have no
responsibilities nothing whatsoever
because I don't want people to stress
out on my wedding and so I always feel
weird like if I ask a homie to to war
get my wedding yeah you know unless they
really really want to do that thing
right they're like hey man I would love
to do this for you I'm like cool we'll
just come on and do it but it would be
hard for me to put all this
responsibility on them right so you know
uh sure and all the guests and
everything else I'm just gonna hire out
people like you yes some minimum wage
have somebody uh sure people they a
staff man yeah all you got to do is just
look nice and drink up that's all you
got to do that's a great all you gotta
do is just stand up there and then the
rest of the night just drink yeah I
don't even want speeches just because I
know how bad [ __ ] best men and [ __ ]
Bryce made speeches are yeah [ __ ]
terrible dude I had this one friend so
so this was at a friend's wedding and it
was one of the it was a great wedding
but it was terrible because the deejay
that they hired I don't know what the
[ __ ] I think this fool was like get
coming off of some [ __ ] high yeah
because he came to the [ __ ] wedding
sweating through his tuxedo just pale
skin dark circle under his eyes and he
was supposed to be the emcee as well the
DJ and the emcee yeah and so the bride
is freaking out now mind you I I didn't
want to emcee the [ __ ] wedding
well [ __ ] give me the mic so I took
the mic and I started emcee the wedding
and then I allowed the the best man to
go ahead and speak now the best man he
gave one of the worst [ __ ] speeches
I've ever heard in my life
so like he literally comes up and I we
labeled this his speech I was born with
the curse because he kept talking about
himself and didn't talk about the bride
or the groom he just goes you know when
I first met him he told me my life was
going to be great and it turned out that
he it was a lie my life went into a
downward spiral and and he just talked
about his pain and just like freshened
and the weird part was he goes you know
honestly I always told myself if I if I
ever got married I would want a woman
just like him yeah and so we thought he
was trying to come out and so like whoa
and I grabbed the mic I was like okay
sit your ass down dude this is not the
time for that and I pushed them aside I
was like yeah what the [ __ ] he was his
speech was so
people started racing the class just to
shut him up just like it was this
written like he had this was what he was
written written on his iPhone Wow and he
was reading it off it's like he was
planning to say all of this it wasn't
just off the top and he was so [ __ ]
drunk
he took him aside afterwards and he
finished the speech to him that's what
I'm [ __ ] yeah let me ask you
something though first of all I don't
really know anything about your your
past past hmm
so let's talk with so if people don't
know Ben is a dancer there's an
entrepreneur there's a whole litany of
things that he is what when did you
first start dancing it started in high
school I think it was like my sophomore
year I mean prior to that I just like
any other Asian kid you know the kids
breakdancing locking yeah all that [ __ ]
poppin and lock-in all of it and you
know I was kind of a chubby kid growing
up to be honest so I had like a bunch of
b-boy friends that I was like okay I'll
try that to be on the ground moving
around like I can't move like that bro
you know I mean it's just too hard and
trying to I know we've all been there
that like that's how the every dancer
origin story is like yeah I saw these
kids breaking at school and I was trying
to do that that wasn't working out too
well for me and then I saw popping I was
like yo they're standing up they're not
even looking like they're breaking a
sweat like that looks like something I
can get down with so then you know this
is prior to YouTube and all that so you
find you know whatever video that you
can get your hands on you just study the
crap out of that so I found like these
old misterwiggles tapes and stuff yeah
and so I just kind of started copying
that and then this is during the time
where MTV actually still played music
videos so you know be watching music
videos from obviously Michael Jackson MC
Hammer or vanilla ice even and I just
kind of started like imitating but the
funny story was I didn't even like so I
was a closeted dancer for about a year
aka I'm just in my room like in front of
a mirror trying to emulate and then
never going outside and showing it off
anywhere because it was just something
that I was just wanting to do for myself
and then my sister she took me to Cape
concert in 8th grade and it was a Lula
yeah that was out in Hollywood Park and
she invited me and I just thought you
know and I'm stupid I'm thinking I'm too
cool for everything some psych-k plastic
that she's like no it's it'll be fun and
it's free blah blah blah and it's xri
fine so I go to it and I'm secretly
enjoying the crap I'm just like inside
I'm just like bursting with joy but I
was just really trying to maintain my
cool like yeah this is cool sorry yeah
and then but then from there I was like
yeah why is kpop so tight because they
were just dancing the whole time onstage
so then I asked my mom to go get me
these like you know those kayo type 10
yeah videos at like the Korean video
store so she was just stoked that I
wanted any any sort of Korean tapes cuz
she just wanted me to like you know like
learn Korean better blah blah blah and
so she got me like a bunch of these
tapes and I watched all of them and I
studied them so there's like h.o.t
chinois like all these groups that were
like big in the early 90 or like mid 90s
yeah
and that was kind of like my intro to so
then I really started to like learn the
choreography from those tapes and then
again still closet no one knew that I
did it until I was like so when I was
going to this church a kid in my youth
group
he kind of was doing the same thing
low-key and then we just somehow kind of
found out you like that [ __ ] fruity
[ __ ] I like that fruity [ __ ] - yeah
that's how it sounds a young man like so
you like learning this stuff - he's like
yeah so you know we should teach each
other so then we would go to each
other's houses like in the living room
off the reflection off of the glass
sliding door cuz we didn't have any you
know mirrors and at that time big enough
and it just kind of started with us
teaching each other and then we started
learning all these routines and then we
found out these like competition talent
shows that were happening these Korean
American talent shows out in like the
valley and that we entered our first one
then we got third place and we're like
you know we got third place like yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] good you know and
then so we just kept doing it kept doing
it and then that just kind of fast
forwarded it into like the whole there's
this whole
like collegiate you know competitive
dance circuit you know that I was
exposed to this is like in the early
2000s and just kind of took it from
there and when I got into college I you
know got down with Kaaba modern which is
the collegiate dance team just kept
going man kapa modern sounds so familiar
Kaaba modern was on a BDC season oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah just funny so that was like my old
team and then I was with Jabbawockeez
and in on season one of ABDC so I was
technically competing against my old
team but oh [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
winners like Mike song you know who's
you know kynges he's a you know
co-founder of King just before King just
he was on Kaaba modern but the funny
thing was like we were homies from back
in the day too so for us to be on that
show competing against each other was
funny wait that's so interesting so oh
that's weird for you I
so Kaaba modern and Jabba they were on
the first season together it's been so
long I can't remember yeah oh holy [ __ ]
I was over a decade ago man and cop
martyr came in second no they
technically were like third they were
the third runner-up and everyone was
pissed
well who got second exactly now so
there's a team they're based out of
Boston they're called status quo and I
don't remember them at all that's a
funny thing man everyone remembers Kaba
modern and Jabbawockeez and about who
was that middle group that technically
got a second yeah everyone knows that
Kaba modern should have been up there I
mean it should have been us at the
finals going head to head but apparently
there's some TV politics saying that
they didn't want to West Coast crews
going at it so they needed like an East
versus West sort of thing so they made
status quo which is from Boston and then
yo for some reason I thought it was
Jabbawockeez in cabo Martin that wasn't
the last time people thought that but no
that wasn't it
Oh what the [ __ ] that's so crazy people
don't know about a lot of the
behind-the-scenes stuff though they
think like everything is as pure as it
can be like they won because of this
this and that's like no there are
producers that are working their way
through these shows all the [ __ ] time
sorry guys reality TV ain't real so when
you when you join Jabbawockeez where you
you were still a copper copper modern
member no so so I was in Kaaba modern
2000 4 to 5 while I was still a student
at UCI
and then I graduated no 5 I still stayed
on the team for a little bit but you
know I was already back in LA working
and stuff so it's just hard for me to go
back and forth from like the valley to
yeah
Irvine so I I left the I left Kaaba and
o-5 and then I just kind of started
pursuing my solo sort of like dancer
choreographer career so I I graduated
over 5 from UCI with the Film Studies
degree I thought I wanted to get into
film or TV production I was working at
MTV just doing P a grunt work and stuff
all the while I was just kind of seeing
all my homies kind of pursuing their
commercial dance industry stuff yeah and
I was just very curious about that as a
man like can I do that stuff but that
this was at a time to where there
weren't a lot of Asians kind of being
placed in these sort of commercial
industry jobs there's only a couple of
people that I knew who were actually
doing and successful and one of them was
actually one of my homies now who's what
part of the Kim's his name is JD McElroy
he was pretty much the one in that one
Asian dude in every Beyonce Chris Brown
yeah sure so I just hit him up and I was
like bro how do you do that like what if
I wanted to do that what do I need to do
is I do you need to get an agent you
need to you know you just got to get out
there you got to get people to you know
know who you are and get your work out
there and so I was working so much at
MTV I was like dude this is taking up
way too much time and and all the while
like even when I was at work I'd be like
secretly like looking up dance videos
like man this is not for me and I had a
conversation with JD one time I was on
AIM and you know it's like young man so
like what should I do I got this kind of
a solid job but like I don't want to see
if I can go pursue this and he was like
well is that job something that you can
kind of come back to later on in life I
was like yeah and he's like well dance
is probably something you want to try
now if anything right am i yeah well
your joints are good it's all nice and
lubed up at least I was like alright
dude that that's it so I quit my job
there I just kind of started like
hustling man just started going to I got
homies that were you know signed to
agency they set me up with meetings I
got an agent started kind of going out
to you know classes and
then I'm started submitting my resume
you know these are times where paper
resumes are still the thing and trying
to get like teaching jobs and start
subbing classes here and there and then
in Oh 6 was right when so jabbawockee
started in oh three and I kind of we
would just kind of all find each other
at the same events you know that that's
the the thing with the dance community
it's pretty tight-knit you know and
there's there's like these big shows
that happen throughout the year up and
down California and pretty much all the
illest from anywhere would show up at
these shows yeah and so I started kind
of meeting them individually you know
and then I guess at the time because I
was rocking with Kaaba modern they a lot
of them knew who I was because I oh yeah
you're that dude on Kaaba and I was like
oh yeah you know like I'm done and all
this and that so kind of just through
the natural you know like mingling at
these events we kind of started kicking
it and then they would start inviting me
like you know you should come in session
with us and this and that and KB Kevin
Brewer he he started his own kind of
side project outside of Jabbawockeez in
oh six oh seven and it was called super
galactic beat manipulators and he showed
up to one of the classes that I taught
in San Diego and also what the hell was
KB doing over here as I'm sure right
because I'm a big fan of this dude and
he was like yellow man I'm starting my
own squad like would you be down to get
down I'm like hell yeah and I'm living
in the valley at this time yes in San
Diego but I didn't care that I'm I'll
Drive make the drive cuz you know at the
time it was just it was worth it you
know I mean cuz though dance was all I
wanted to do and so just kind of getting
down with KB for you know a couple years
there to you know meeting some of the
other guys on the side it was like in oh
seven where they were just this is
before any of the TV stuff happened
before America's Best Dance Crew they
went on America's Got Talent
that's right season one actually and
yeah right before they went on that they
asked me though yo like would you would
you want to get down and I'm like of
course you know so then we did the whole
like classic you know we're gonna battle
you
it was like 3 a.m. we went down into
fees parking garage and NoHo we started
as a cat of his trunk and I had to go
rounds up against each one of those guys
and that's like getting jumped into a
gang it's dance
I got dance jumped in that's not good
tight dude yeah pop lock the [ __ ] out of
your face [ __ ] I got battled in man and
then and then a year later was when 2008
was when we did a BDC and then we won
that show and then things just took off
man Vegas all that that's kind of crazy
the whole Jabbawockeez thing I feel like
America's Best Dance Crew I don't know
where that show is like now in terms of
what's done now yeah but the the
influence that it had on dance was
unreal because it was such an
underground thing yeah you know there
was battle of the year you know there's
freestyle session there's all the stuff
that everybody knew about yeah but all
it was very niche right so nobody really
kind of unless you were into b-boying or
you had friends that dance you didn't
really know what the [ __ ] it was right
b-boying and I feel like just in the
b-boy scene alone because of the
Internet it evolved into this crazy
thing like if you see for example just
something small right like I remember
back in the day
just get it haven't somebody having an
air flare was unreal right it was
unlucky real yeah but then the internet
starting to happen and people started
innovating constantly I'm like you what
the [ __ ] is that people start doing
chair flares I'm like what the [ __ ] is a
chair flare dude how do you do that and
not break your arm yeah but now now I
see like a lot of these European
people's right and they're [ __ ] it
they're [ __ ] airpower is unreal the
creativity is there and you know like
Korea was on top of that [ __ ] right and
they still are but then I feel like a
lot of these European cats they really
innovated air power to like another
[ __ ] level and I can't even
comprehend how you even think about this
[ __ ] yeah but like stuff like America's
Best Dance Crew was a huge catalyst for
people to really you know get into dance
because back in the day like I remember
if people wanted to dance they would do
it at a garage there was [ __ ] studios
every left and right corner there was
ballet studios it was
jazz dance studios but how many places
did you know how to hip hop studio where
people can be boy dance pop whatever
like if you wanted to get down you had
to learn through somebody else almost do
like apprenticeship but now there's like
classes for people right there's moving
lifestyle there was one that you were
pup boogie zone or some [ __ ] like that
but yeah oh jeez own that was out in OC
I think now they're in like South Bay
Torrance area yeah it's kind of crazy
like how I see especially some of these
young people how amazing they are
dancing it's like dude there's adults
that want to dance like these kids and
they can't [ __ ] do it yeah and
there's this talent pool that's coming
up that's blowing my [ __ ] mind yeah I
think that's the thing that I mean I
think you hit it on the head because of
the internet and you know you to now
Instagram you know I think it's
literally anything that you want to
learn is accessible just by like typing
it up and I think with the younger
generation these kids that are growing
up but I think kids are naturally
they're just sponges you know I mean
like they can learn anything and and the
kids are the ones that are the fearless
one so they're gonna try that crazy air
flare thing fall on their head and get
them you know if I try that fall I'm I'm
done dude like there's no way I'm even
attempting that again but I think with
combining you know the resources of
YouTube the internet with these kids
that are just down to learn and be
sponges they are getting information
faster more accessible and they can look
up other people who do it differently so
they have this variety now of just
offering and then they can now take it
into a dance studio because with us too
we didn't have any density we're doing
it in our garage in our living room
floor so you know we just have limited
space limited resources but now I think
you know with internet what it is people
are becoming super talented at a very
young age therefore because I think even
you know during the time when I was
growing up there were child prodigies
but it was that one kid yeah that one
area and then he was just like so famous
but now my kid David like he was yes the
dude you know I'm watching kid David I
like who the [ __ ] is this guy he helped
do super [ __ ] young but there's a not
not to take away from kid David but
there's a lot of kid David's now like
were young people that are on his level
of talent and he at the time like I just
remember watching him like this [ __ ]
guy's crazy yeah like it's unreal yeah
this is the dancing is such a
crazy thing III think like the one of
the things to that I do see a lot though
specifically from I you know I talk to a
lot of dancers they they kind of see
this thing where kids will emulate a lot
but they're not getting their own style
that's also the the positive and the
detriment of it right so I see a lot of
kids who I'm like I know that dance
because I saw Mike do that yeah I saw
Ben do that or I saw [ __ ] Phil do
this I'm like yeah you're just like a
kind of like a damn what the [ __ ]
somebody getting arrested right now
[ __ ] up my podcast rely on these
streets of Glendale yeah some Armenian
dude is robbing some poor little Korean
lady but but yeah they be kind of like
they sample a lot which is great I think
as a great foundation I just sometimes
see a lot of stuff repetitive where
they're not doing their own yeah thing
right so I think that's the cool part
where you get to see somebody who's yeah
you dance but you don't dance you know
what I mean so I kind of start to wonder
like you know when [ __ ] if this
cop doesn't arrest this fool just going
around a circle like a cartoon
characters you know yeah but I feel like
sometimes like I see some of these
dancers and I like kind of glaze over it
it's it's like the same concept with
YouTube a lot of people had the same
content because people are picking what
everybody else does but they're not
improving on it yeah and I see that
sometimes with dance yeah
you know I think that that's that's so
funny because I think yeah back in the
day you you would catch something you
would see somebody do something and like
more than likely you're not gonna have
it accessible on this you know portable
device readers watch the crap out of it
and learn it to the tee you might have
seen it once or twice and then you take
it home and then you you do what you
think it was yeah cuz at the end of the
day that's how anyone learns you're
gonna see somebody do something it's
like I want to learn that and then you
learn it the way that you think it's
done and a lot of I think a lot of
originality from back in the day came
from kind of almost by mistake you know
you you kind of doing something in a way
that you think it's supposed to be done
but you actually tweak it some somehow
different cuz you you're your own person
you're not gonna be able to literally
regurgitate something you saw once and
then you know someone will see sigh yo
that's that's an interesting take like
on
windmill like you know like now you're
doing it with like your arms tucked in
like what's that
you know like was like alright that
that's how you supposed to do it you
know and then like people take that and
it just evolves you know what I mean but
I think yeah you said it with with kids
now you know they'll see something and
they you know again it starts with
wanting to emulate but because it's so
easily I can rewind it as much as I want
to be like where did his left hand go at
that time or whatever it they literally
can become you know yeah literally
mimics something and I think you know
that's that's something that and I don't
think you can fault anybody for that
because they they're just having fun
they're doing it because it's fun but
like I think as you know people who are
you know kind of in have been in this
game I think that's why people emphasize
be original you know it's okay to it's
okay to start somewhere and and and even
learn something the way that it was done
from somebody but then take that and
then like inject yourself into it and
see how you can evolve because the hard
part is like I I even see this with
music or any type of art nowadays you
know back in the day if you were a
[ __ ] biter you got called out for a
[ __ ] yeah and people are like well let
livin like this is the phrase I hate the
most
it isn't let them just live like what
the [ __ ] does that mean like you're we
have two separate definitions of let him
just I understand well let him just let
them have fun but the problem with that
is that when it comes to art is that
when you steal somebody's art you're
actually stealing a piece of their
originality and their soul you know like
the the point and the sweat and tears
that it took for them to get this thing
yeah you didn't have to go through that
fire to get to where they're at and you
just took it yeah now mind you you took
it and you gave credit that's a
completely different story because I
know it's like some people go well why
do they need credit they just did it for
the art right no but you're taking a
piece of their harder [ __ ] work yeah
and even just saying hey I learned it
from this guy it makes them feel better
because it shows that what they did
wasn't for not right because let's say
you did something and then you got more
famous off of what they created that's
great for you but you're not giving
respect words do and that's that's the
part of the art there's a little bit of
narcissism to it you know like you can't
deny that [ __ ] yeah there you want to be
recognized for your [ __ ] hard work
and that's anybody and every
yeah so when people allow this whole
biting thing and they're just like oh
well it's okay like what you know a lot
of people who do that [ __ ] are also
people or [ __ ] talentless they go oh
biting is okay cuz you want it you want
it to be okay so you could [ __ ] do it
too and that's what I hate
it's like pay homage and pay for [ __ ]
respect yeah I totally agree I think
this is like a great topic because I
think people have opinions on that right
like what is what is biting and what is
inspiration and and all of that and I
think there's there's a fine line there
but just what you said crediting the
people that you know have taught you or
that you're inspired by and and I think
it doesn't always even have to be like
oh this person personally taught me he's
like no I I watched this person on
YouTube or I saw this here and then I
thought that was dope and so like shout
out blah blah blah for doing whatever
and you know this is where I've been
inspired by and then you take it
somewhere else and so I think the the
crediting side is definitely you know
like yeah that's very important in terms
of because I think at the end of the day
yeah you're making someone who created
it or maybe kind of you know was a part
of the origination of something like
feel better it's like yes this was
something shouted me out like thank you
you know and I think a lot of people
that are kind of in the space that kind
of have grown up through the
pre-internet and we're kind of doing it
on that garage kid level and then
internet popped up and we like you know
like I would say I'm from that
generation cuz yeah I was I was doing
this before YouTube in any of that and
then I kind of caught up late to all
this stuff I'm like what is this YouTube
thing that everybody's talking about yo
there's a lot of stuff out there and you
know even from the days from
Jabbawockeez and like you know there was
there were crews like in in Asia like
Philippines and stuff that were
literally ripping oh I saw that she the
masks and the whole thing the routine
and the [ __ ] and and and and yeah it was
it like it pissed it pissed people off
because it's like you know these guys
are literally on TV in the Philippines
like yeah get getting paid off of this
stuff and Jabbawockeez still over here
trying to figure it out trying to make
you know so I think in those in that
context
that whole thing was Bhutan but finding
a biter that's what you are Patong in a
biter you piece a pill but you you
[ __ ] I swear to God I [ __ ]
kill you you [ __ ] son of a beech I
started I remember when I she came out I
was like what the [ __ ]
at least let me try let me try to make
it some like even a little bit didn't
even try yeah
they literally took it and they were
making money off of your guys's artwork
and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] irritating
yeah you know and there were certain
comments they're like well they're doing
it just as good so what's the problem I
was like people who say that are ones
who want to steal and be okay with it do
you want to be able to steal and say
like well they did it too because if you
were somebody who had just a little bit
of just decency he would never write
something like that yeah because you
wouldn't you wouldn't know how hurtful
it is to work that hard in somebody to
take your artistry that [ __ ] is it's
it's it's it sucks
you know when I was on YouTube there was
this kid back in the day I think he got
I [ __ ] roasted this kid like I
literally he literally took the the
videos that I was doing and just put it
on his own Channel and just changed his
name and I was like those are my exact
jokes I was like what the [ __ ] yeah and
I roast this guy he deleted all those
videos but there was a couple of
comments there like well he's making
people laugh what's the problem
and I'm like see and you are the exact
type of [ __ ] that I'm talking about like
no I'll be it when I had these videos
back in the day they were like failed
stand a bit so I just put it in vlogs I
was like it might be funny to some
people I don't really know but at the
end of they still mine and even if you
gave me credit you still shouldn't use
it because he's making money off of my
work so as I was working this on a stand
up stage and it was bombing and I had to
go through that embarrassment and put it
on this video you know you're taking
you're making money off my work like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude like I I know people
some people might think that's petty but
it's not it's hard work yeah I agree I
agree and I think that's the thing is I
mean well at least I mean not to say
that it was good or okay because he
credited you but I mean at least he
didn't credit me oh he didn't credit I
thought yes the fans they're like yo
this guy's stealing your [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah I mean again I think you know
inspiration is is taking something that
that you dig that you that you vibe with
but you have to flip it you have
to inject something else into it in
order for it to be your own thing
because at the end of the day I mean you
know you can't reinvent the wheel like
ten times over I mean it's over shit's
already there and everything's been done
already yeah any you know from you know
a joke to a dance move to you know a
song
someone's gonna start something and that
is gonna like it's gonna spin off into
something else that looks or sounds or
kind of feels like that but there's
something different about that and and I
think that's what art that's why arts
beautiful because I think you can see
how something can start somewhere and
then evolve into this and even if you
look at you know art movements in like
painting and stuff like that there was
all these different things that these
artists were doing and they would look
at that and then they would take that
and go do something else so that's why
there's so many genres from you know
from you know visual arts to music to
you know comedy and all that I think
there's but that's the beauty of it and
it's dope to be able to see something
like dang that's tight I kind of feels
like this so it looks like that but they
took it here you know and then it
becomes this game that I feel like keeps
art going you know what I mean I think
that's what's dope about it yeah you
know just to just to clarify for other
people not everybody's gonna be that
person that's gonna be able to take that
and then evolve it into something else I
think that should be a goal and there's
a that's something that should people
should attempt like I think my biggest
issue is when you take it and then you
say that you didn't get it from anywhere
it's like oh [ __ ] talk about a slap to
the [ __ ] face you know what I mean
it's like if you're up there and then
people ask you go home I just [ __ ]
figured it out myself
yeah you [ __ ] did yeah you know give
credit where credit's due like oh no
people talk about Stan like you're right
especially in comedy I see similar
standard bits all the [ __ ] time all
the [ __ ] time all the same jokes
about marriage relationships whatever
but their twist is how they experienced
it in their relationship or how they
expressed it through their lens so yeah
it's technically the same joke but not
really at the same time and that's the
way that you innovated and you know some
people might have an argument where they
go okay well we'll give me an example
that indents this is my favorite example
like I see two three people that I know
that dance not the same but they kind of
had that
same swag but is same indifferent right
so it's that kid schizo and the and the
les twins mm-hmm they have a similar
vibe specifically the way they dance the
way they hit beats the way they groove
it's very similar right but it's so
[ __ ] different at the same time yeah
and I think that's where people can see
if you guys don't know who these people
are like in the dance scene check it out
and you'll see what I mean like the
group is very similar but they're
completely different dancers and that's
an example of innovation and just kind
of having your own style to it
that kids get so [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah like when I saw him dancers like
who the [ __ ] is this he's super young
too isn't he yeah [ __ ] where's he from
I'm not sure not sure he's from he
dancing I think he dances in Vegas right
or something like that I think he's like
in the Michael Jackson show or some [ __ ]
like that but that was a [ __ ] in
single the twins were in the in the
Michael Jackson show too which is oh
really yeah if that's actually true
that's oh [ __ ] that's unreal they were
there they were on what that's all you
think you did well the dance world the
dance we are so we were on so season one
which was like a crazy season I thought
it was so speaking of like dance and
that [ __ ] was crazy it was crazy because
the I mean the level of talent you know
on that show I mean still happening and
the talent is crazy but season one was
crazy cuz you know we were on kynges
were on there Jabbawockeez weren't on
there the twins was on there keone and
Mari Ian Eastwood there's like so like
literally the best of all the categories
were competing on that one stage in
season one and of course it's TV man so
there's we always have to remember like
we've learned from doing it you know
from a people are pulling strings it's
it's a show man it's it's entertainment
when the walkies lost everybody's like
wow that was that was so weird bogus man
like like not even just people who are
like dick riding the walkies or whatever
it was just it was hard you believe like
what the [ __ ] happened yeah the whole
internet exploded they're like what like
what are you talking about you know what
I mean it was such a weird thing I don't
know what happened there but and I
actually what like yeah I'm glad we're
talking about this because so yeah I
mean I was a part of the Jabbawockeez so
people were thinking like yo is this
gonna be weird for you yeah competing
against your own squad and I'm like 100%
it's gonna be weird like yes
like you know these are my brothers like
I spent so much time you know learning
from these guys literally living life
with these guys and you know life
happens and I'm back here in LA and then
I'm over here with kynges and like that
was something that I didn't know that
was gonna happen so it's just more like
holy crap what is life right now yeah I
mean so I'm just like all right we're
here we are but I look at I look at
things like that as an opportunity for
for growth and and it's sure it's tough
like you you know you're you see
something that you have a past with you
see your current situation
it's kind of like you know you see your
ex at a at a restaurant and you're with
your current girlfriend you like they do
I go talk to her like yeah you know that
but for me I'm just like no like this is
life you know what I mean and and and I
always do whatever I can to be like yo
dude I wanna express gratitude or
gratitude is do and just continue to
live forward with where I'm at now and
so that was a great opportunity for me
because like that was me being in that
same space with Jabbawockeez since I
left and and it was dope to me you know
what I mean and I was able to interact
with literally all those guys again and
it was dope man yeah and so for me
thinking about like oh my gosh like this
full circle is insane you know yeah and
like here we are now technically on this
competition platform competing against
each other but that first season because
of who was there everybody was so stoked
to be there because they saw everyone
else that was there that like you know I
can't believe I'm keeping competing
against you know
keone and Mari and like the twins are
here and like you know super crews
they're like all the hitters came to
play and it just became this like
technically a competition but it was
everybody just there to just kind of
like feed off of each other and it's
ultimately like it was just a big
inspiration pool you know but
specifically that that episode where
Jabbawockeez got eliminated it blew
everybody's minds because that round was
like a battle round yeah the duals and
they came to bat it came to battle and
they were roasty
with it and like you no note no shade to
Ian Eastwood and in the young lines they
killed it their army I think even they
were shocked they were like yeah yeah
because I think it was you know
yeah they understood the nature what
this round was and I don't know what the
judges saw I mean you know if it was up
to audience votes I think it'll
definitely win a different way but you
know for whatever reason I don't know
I'm not I'm not in those producing rooms
and stuff like that but that shouldn't
have happened in the battle round it
shouldn't have Gandhi yeah cuz the theme
was battle right and I felt like Ian
Eastwood he didn't really came come to
battle so I was like oh he didn't really
like kill the theme very well yeah but
the walkies did I was like oh this is a
no-brainer yeah and you know just like
on a TV sense right why would you
eliminate one of the most popular crews
out of this show like literally all the
comments were like I'm done with the
show yeah it's like that's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing to do and everybody was
shot just like did did what happened
behind the stage like the scenes like
everybody was just like just dumbfounded
didn't make any [ __ ] sense bro your
reactions were the same as ours man it
was so [ __ ] insane man but it's kind
of weird like how many shows you guys
have done I do you do you feel nervous
every time you do it 100% and I think
nerve-racking I feel like if if I don't
get nervous it must mean I'd really
don't care about that you know what I
mean so I think for me I've learned to
kind of embrace my nervous nervousness
and the fear of what could happen
because I feel like it keeps me in this
kind of heightened state of mind and you
know like you think and I think those
nerves are I mean I'm sure for you to
like I mean I don't want to know like
you know when you step onto a stage
where you feel like I need to kill this
your next effects I got this right like
I'm sweating ball but like I think
that's the thing like any time I step on
and what I you know honesty and I thank
God for this because I think there was a
time where I didn't mean maybe take
every opportunity as seriously as I
should aka like if I'm thinking like ah
this is kind of a smaller show I'm not
sweating it
you know and then I mess up or something
like that you know and then dang I
messed up you know and I was just like
well how did I mess up this because I
kind of went into it with this attitude
I just like whatever I got this and so I
think you know over the years like I've
just you know grown just to be like you
know every stage you step on regardless
of you're performing in front of 30
people or 3,000 like treat that the same
you know I mean like be thankful for
these opportunities be thankful for them
the people that came out to support you
too you know just because it's a TV show
doesn't mean that it that's bigger than
you know performing at an elementary
school with these kids or whatever so
but yeah I mean just to answer your
question the nerves I feel like are
always there but I lean into that and
that actually helps me perform better oh
[ __ ] that's crazy I run away from the
show you know when you left when you
left like the walkies I mean that was
such a big move for you I mean I feel
like because you guys built such a huge
Empire together and you kind of in like
you said to that you kind of went into
this and then the whole canjust thing
happened I mean well what led you to
leaving the walkie I mean that's such a
like for me like I always look at it
from an outside perspective and I'm like
[ __ ] man like that would be like trying
to rip my own skin off because it'd
become such a huge part of your identity
right especially because it even now who
doesn't know who the [ __ ] walkies are
yeah like little kids right but as a
dancer you you know who these people are
and that's such an iconic group to leave
and then you guys I mean obviously you
did really well creating your other
thing but how what was the decision that
led you to do that and what was the
reasons yeah man that was a tough one
bro cuz you know that was so 2010 to
2014 was our hours in Vegas which I walk
we got our show in 2010 and we you know
we're just out there grinding building
this thing and and paving you know new
ground for for dance because as far as I
know no one in history is you know
within the hip-hop urban dance kind of
category was able to headline a Las
Vegas show so yeah you know obviously
just the
the experiences that I had there were
amazing that money can't buy that stuff
yeah but it was a second that year of
2013 I was going through a lot of just
personal stuff you know from you know
relationship that didn't work out to
just me personally feeling that I kind
of was losing a sense of myself and and
a lot of that was just me not even like
I didn't even really know where God was
that in my life though I would always
say that I had a relationship like
there's a lot of stuff that was
happening that that whole year of 2013 I
started to just feel this sense of
something needs to change you know and I
couldn't put my finger on it like in
terms of like what am I really feeling
like what do I need to change and a lot
of it was an unwillingness to change
because I felt comfortable you know just
like you know but you know making money
and I'm dancing you know it's cool it's
fun and like there was just this quiet
voice you know somewhere in the back
where I didn't know what that was and I
was trying to ignore it was saying like
this is not for you you know yeah
and so yeah I just kind of try to ignore
but it just got louder and louder and
things were just happening life was
happening and all the while like my
family everybody that you know all my
friends and stuff obviously you know
besides my crew who was out there it was
still here in LA and for whatever reason
I just felt like man I just want to go
back home dude I just want to go back to
LA and and all and there's a lot of
other things happening where I was just
even second-guessing dance in general
like is this even still for you you know
like do you even have it still like that
and you know maybe this was a good run
you know maybe it's time to go figure
out life put your big-boy pants on and
go get that quote-unquote real job or
whatever and yeah dude it was a whole
process of a year and you know there was
just a lot of transition happening with
my personal life to what was going on
you know out in Vegas to what I was be
feeling drawn to in LA that it was just
this you know we I sat down with the
guys and we had this talk and and I was
so afraid to have this topic
I didn't know what I was gonna say I
didn't know what the outcome was gonna
be and of course the fear of the unknown
is the worst it could be so paralyzing
but that conversation and the way that
things kind of just happened was like oh
this is so meant to be there was like
there wasn't this sense of like ah dang
like I shouldn't have said that or like
ah like why is this happening more just
like whoa I think this is the right
choice you know what I mean and and so
for me I felt like men and I you know
I've always been a fan of the Japanese I
was at the very first Jabbawockeez
performance in 2003 in the in audience
just as a fan and this was before again
this is the first performance in life so
no one even knew what the heck could
Jabberwocky was like the way that it was
spelled in the program was like not it
not yes it is just like beta phase
freaking blew my mind man and I just
knew that like these guys are gonna
change the world somehow I'm like and
I'm tripping out by myself watching this
and like the rest of the audience is
just quiet and I'm sorry you guys not
seeing this is insane and so I knew at
that moment that this is they're gonna
be the biggest in like for me to to
actually be a part of that group was
just like wait how how did this happen
yeah yeah yeah dream come true and I and
you know and I told the guys you know in
my like kind of final sort of meeting
with them I was like man I started as a
fan day one and I'm a fan now and I'm
gonna be a fan for life you know to me
and so that that that's something that
I'm gonna carry with me forever and you
know I had no idea what was on the other
side of of that move in terms of coming
to LA there was not honestly I wasn't
even planning to dance anymore like I
said I just kind of felt like I fell out
of love with it it just was like a
love-hate sort of thing because it just
I just associated so much of you know
the drama that was going on in my life
that everything was just tied in
together and I just felt like I need to
just maybe step away from all of this
you know the mean and so when I came
back to LA you know I had no job lined
up I had no idea what I was gonna do
thank God I you know had some sense to
have some money saved up so I was like
cool I got some runway you know I'll
figure it out
and and then when I got back to LA so
Mike and Anthony who are the founders of
kynges they found it in 2010 and it was
just like a homies like fun crew they
would get together you know every so
often to put together a show and then
they would just kind of go do their
individual like dancer hustle now that
was when Mike and Anthony were there
doing the whole YouTube thing on the
solo tip and they're killing it you know
they're traveling the world teaching and
all that but the timing I guess
of 2014 was when they were kind of
getting tired doing their own individual
hustle and they were like man it's just
not fun traveling alone I mean like it's
suck yeah yeah octa can you jack off in
a hotel man it's just him after a while
he's got no juice left cuz like [ __ ] man
[ __ ] this [ __ ] dude I was gonna not do
it today sucks and you got a girlfriend
like [ __ ] I can't do nothing is that the
jag off and go to my hotel look at this
all the [ __ ] the sheets are all
crusty I was like man you need changed
my sheets immediately yeah man so these
guys they were just kind of in this you
know in this space of we're tired of
doing the own you know solo thing like
let it be way more fun to do it together
you know so they were just like man
let's let's start pouring all of our
focus into kynges you know let's hit up
the homies that you know that we're down
with the squad at the time then you know
we'd to see who's down to actually pour
into this thing and that was the time
that I had come back to LA so I've known
Mike for man probably over 15 years now
man his college right yeah well before
cause he was in high school when I first
met him he acts oh yeah he started
dancing like after kind of seeing me and
my little kpop group perform at like a
UCLA Korean culture night and you know
he's this high school kid who's like yo
this looks tiny [ __ ] but you so he kind
of started you know in high school after
kind of being inspired by you know my
group too you know things that you know
from Wiggles and all that stuff too so
he kind of started there so when he went
to college he came to UC I he hit me up
cuz he knew that I was there and he was
a young man I'm coming to UCI I want to
dance like what team
getting down with and I was like bro you
got to get down with cop modern bro he
already know and he's like alright well
let me check you guys out Lena so he
came to one of the performances and he
was like yeah ok cool I want to dance
acaba so that way you know from there we
got tighter ABDC happened and so we
we've just kind of stayed you know just
in contact over the years that's a good
circle dude yeah and Mike and Mike and
Antonia actually were the first swing
swings for the Jabbawockeez show they
were in Vegas and they were doing the
show they were kind of like our our you
know Swing castings yeah
and so when Mike was out here I knew he
was grinding you know so we just
connected just we grabbed lunch one time
he's like what's up man what are you
doing here am i I'm here for how long
I'm like for good and he just like what
what is what does that mean I'm like
yeah he's like what about you know Vegas
and Jeff walk he's like yeah man I'm
just I'm back dude I left I'm just
trying to figure out life right now and
you know he was kind of in this you know
Mike's very good at kind of reading a
situation today oh okay
you cool you know I'm like yeah man I'm
good all right well if you need anything
man let me know I was like for sure you
know and so it was just one of those
like I'm kickin it with my homies cuz I
just felt like I needed to be around
people be around people that like homies
from you know back in the day and stuff
and we fast forward to I go on this road
trip you know Mike and Anthony were
traveling cross-country just driving and
then they were just visiting landmarks
that they've always wanted to see this
is kind of like a bucket list thing for
them and so they knew that I was back in
LA so they were like y'all man if you're
not doing anything like come out to the
Grand Canyon we're gonna be in Arizona
like on Monday meet us out there I was
like cool I got no job I got nothing to
do so I rolled out there with my homies
Sean and you know we were just like it
was so perfect because we were not like
dance I mean we were kind of you know
here and there we would talk about it
maybe even session a little bit but we
were just on some life tip just like
talking about you know like what are you
learning right now you know like what
are you into like what do you want to do
right now and it was just tell there's
I'm Anthony Lee [ __ ] yeah you know if
that [ __ ] meditated anymore this
[ __ ] would float to JK news it
feels so spiritual
[ __ ] you I love that guy he's just like
he's such a nice guy I'm just like he
just turned 33 man so he's on his he's
on his manhood right now you know I'm
surprised he's he doesn't like patchouli
oil and [ __ ] like eating veganism you
shouldn't like that he's a vegetarian he
was for a bit we all were for a bit
because the [ __ ] Steven and Michael
huh well so yeah shout out impact and
villain you called Steven Michael oh
yeah that's right that's their that's
their that's their dancing game yeah The
Wiggles and pickles they're they're
vegan
the vegan twinges but I know for us we
watched that documentary on Netflix what
the health I don't you seen it how that
[ __ ] propaganda bomb
hey I've seen all these other ones like
cowspiracy and all these other ones none
of those did anything to me but what the
health is so conspiracy mad not a
conspiracy but there was a lot of just
[ __ ] up facts on it I mean I
definitely know there's bias i watch the
document you got another is biased I
wish I just had some empathy man cuz
every time I see you know remember that
one documentary what's it called the
[ __ ] the fast-food one supersize
supersize right so when I saw that [ __ ]
and that guy was getting fattening the
burger I was jealous I was like [ __ ] I
want a [ __ ] burger so bad right now
and it did it could turn me I actually
got McDonald's after and I don't even
like McDonald's at the time dude
so it actually got me to eat McDonald's
that [ __ ] documentary dude so are you
are you vegetarian vegan I am I've been
vegetarian for vegetarians I feel like I
could be vegetarian yeah it's it's
doable because one I mean I still eat
eggs
I still eat dairy I'm good then so yes
all I need yeah you good and in that
what I realized so people ask me there
and anytime I talk to like somebody who
goes vegetarian or vegan what's the
first question they always ask so do you
feel different you know you feel better
Am I honestly I fart a lot that's true
too you said a lot of fiber that happens
but uh I was like honestly I feel the
same and they're like Oh what I'm like
but so that's the good thing I don't
feel different
I don't feel less energy or I don't feel
more tired I can still like go to the
gym work out I still feel like I get the
same results that I want so I'm still
getting my protein from plant-based
products and stuff so for me it was more
of if I'm not losing anything by taking
meat out of my diet that
must mean it's a good thing cuz it's not
like I'm helping myself by eating a ton
of me cuz I know like as much as the
documentary there's bias in there I
definitely feel like there is absolute
correlation between you know meat
products and and metabolic disease I
mean that's just you know people from
heart disease to cancer to high blood
pressure
Gow all that stuff that's like think
that all that stuff though like that you
saw is also in conjunction so the the
problem with that documentary is that
they don't people don't ever do
conclusive studies based on people's
previous diet before right so for
example a lot of people will do this and
I this is only stuff that I looked up
because you know I lost a lot of weight
we so I had to do thorough research yeah
to a certain extent anyways but they
they'll do stuff like this they say go
meat is bad because it causes
inflammation blah blah blah but what are
you eating with that me hmm are you
having a high carb diet is it also high
fat is that income in conjunction with
processed foods mm-hm or is it just the
meat alone so those are the scientific
studies that people don't talk about
right so there's a lot of people who go
into veganism vegetarianism right cuz it
does wonders for them and the reason why
is because of this when you when you do
that and you switch your diet you're
also being coming more mindful about
what you put in your bio which is what
you weren't doing before but if you did
a conclusive study against somebody who
did eat protein but they also ate a lot
of vegetables they didn't need processed
foods a lot of sugars with that person's
diet or health be as worse or better or
the same as somebody who just went
vegetarian mmm so those are the things
that are really different right yeah so
for example one of the things that
helped me lose weight a lot and what I
found out was that I would do two things
that were really messed up so your body
tends to have two sources of energy
you're either a fat burner or you're a
car burner that's really about it
right so problematically what happens is
people mix both so here's a great
example of something it's terrible for
you Pizza mm-hmm - high carb your body
only burns one source of that energy and
if you're a car burner what happens to
that fat it just becomes stored and this
is this is just like basic basic [ __ ]
knowledge and so that's that's where
that difference is it's like when we see
a lot of these documentaries yeah
they'll put these studies out but
they're not talking about than other 80%
yeah right for me I understand
vegetarianism in the sense of like I
think if somebody told me eight yo be
vegetarian for a month I could
definitely do it yeah it's not that hard
like
personal opinion like I don't need to
eat beef I actually only started eating
beef until I was like like really eating
beef when I was like 19 or 20 mm-hmm cuz
I didn't like the taste of it
I thought it tastes like the tasted beef
no didn't I didn't like Iberian I didn't
like bulgogi I don't like any of that
[ __ ] like I like chicken I like shrimp I
like fish that was like my main [ __ ]
okay honestly if somebody told me
pescetarian I could do that tomorrow oh
yeah for the rest of my life and it
wouldn't be a [ __ ] problem it's not
like I have sushi I'm pretty much good
you know but like vegetarianism I feel
like it's easier for Asian people
because we got a lot of [ __ ] yeah I feel
like if you're a white person sorry dude
I've been getting down on a lot of tofu
and I know I lose this [ __ ] so much tofu
is not good to have a lot of whatever
estrogen or whatever in there she gives
you titties that [ __ ] true is that
[ __ ] why I got these shits dude
[ __ ] meat offal all the time dude I
got snot being so [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] little edamame and [ __ ] I know
soy products are good but yo so I mean I
totally agree I think vegetarianism is a
lot easier to do because there's a lot
of other options out there and I eat if
there's a vegan option where I'm at I'll
choose the vegan option but it's just
it's just so inconvenient especially
when you're traveling on Asia about
vegan vegetarianism China they don't
even know what that means bro they're
like yeah it's a vegetable dish and
there's like I'm supporting there like
it's crazy but um yeah I think for me I
I went pretty much a whole year with
just sticking to the vegetarian diet but
again I look at it as like a logical
thing it's what you do what you do
habitually you know what like are part
of your daily rhythms are is what's
gonna have like a long-term effect so
like if you go to the gym once a week
you're not gonna lose weight you're not
gonna get ya buff you know the mean and
same thing with like you know your diet
you know if you like predominantly fill
your diet with a certain type of food or
for sure that's what your your health
benefits are gonna come from that and if
every now and then you eat a piece of
meat or you go out for even a Korean
barbecue once in a blue moon it's not
gonna it's not gonna kill you yeah so I
think for me like I mean I get down dude
Thanksgiving is my favorite holiday so
on Thanksgiving I'm sorry I'm eating my
traditional family Thanksgiving meal cuz
yeah it's just what I love but like my
regular rhythms don't
consists of meat meat products other
than dairy and is one of the bigger
reasons why do you feel B do you feel
bad for the way animals are treated not
at I'm sorry animal animal lovers I love
animals but that's not why good cuz I
chopped a [ __ ] pigs it off right now
I could give up but keep dude I know
dude there were some like vegan and
vegetarian people that hated my guts
they're like you would just kill a
living being like that yes I would I
would I would kill your [ __ ] baby
sister if I had to so don't even talk
about animals to me alright like I hate
you so much if I see one of your sale I
will kick them in the [ __ ] chest I
will eat a pig cow whatever you know
what I do have a problem with them I
can't eat veal because a baby cow baby
cow yeah because I saw a baby cuz you
know Sacramento is a super agricultural
a city so I saw a baby cow [ __ ]
flooding us little eyes I'm like I can't
eat like this stupid I should have never
saw you and it was like licking my hand
and [ __ ] and I was like no I can't I've
never tried have you ever tried it I did
I love that [ __ ] veal Milanese Oh what
what's what's the difference between
veal stander as like filet mignon
tenders cool veal is extra tender so
it's it just has this texture that's
amazing but you know it's a baby cow in
a way that they're treated to like they
don't let them move so they don't
develop a lot of muscles and then they
slaughter it on my uh
at least a cow gets nice and fat and
gets an electric hold up its ass you
know I'm okay I know like I know like
Michael and Steven or I'm sorry impact
and villain impact in volantis - I know
like for them like they're on this vegan
kick yeah pretty sure that if they saw
me the way I eat meat they probably
throw up but you know what's dope about
those guys so they they've been vegan
for years now but they don't they don't
knock people who eat meat they don't
make people feel bad they're like yo man
cuz they're decent human beings yeah
sometimes though I just want to see them
and just eat into eat a rib right from
their face like what you think about
this [ __ ] probably yeah positive
[ __ ] God dude those guys are so
positive man they're so spiritual [ __ ]
it's crazy because their mom and I know
[ __ ] is he pig blood but then I did
straight-up know me that's what I'm
saying so when they told me before they
were vegan they'd literally ate the
crazy meat yeah crazy [ __ ] that I'm like
yo I don't even know people eat that
stuff yeah they would love it that's cuz
they got scared out of me
that's why maybe that's [ __ ] crazy I
remember watching your guys's like in
stories and I was like everybody is
becoming a [ __ ] me oh did this [ __ ]
stop
well the [ __ ] video [ __ ] cut out but
I know I was wearing my jacket earlier
for cotton because it's getting hot so k
I got I got this [ __ ] we need to pull
over my dick boater yeah but Michael and
Steve are super nice and I'm known then
since high school they were dancing wow
they were in a crew called the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] would they call it was fun
it was funny ask named oh the psycho six
or some [ __ ] and that wedding to do be
boy names were the funniest [ __ ] on
earth dude like you had to somehow make
it hard but not weird at the same time
there was like they went psycho sick
then they had they had underground flow
after that and they're still going on to
this day
underground flow EGF is killing it right
now Michael and Steven were always the
most talented ones no man yeah they just
they were just always about it do you
ever get down with those guys abso [ __ ]
well you think I'm fat now do you she
saw me back in the day and god damnit
but I always loved dance because
everybody dance you know I think
everybody tried like I tried I was like
man this [ __ ] ain't not for me dude and
I cannot do this so I stuck to a guitar
I was like [ __ ] it some-something gotta
get me [ __ ] the dancing of music so I
went the music instead yeah but dancing
was always always something that you
know I think everybody you know it's
funny about that I think so earlier
we're talking about ABDC and like the
whole TV thing that kind of put at least
dance crews were kind of spotlighted in
in that show because before that So You
Think You Can Dance was happening and
then you know through the commercial
dancing you would some sometimes he
asian people out there doing it but a
BDC season one was this weird sort of
phenomenon because prior to that that
stereotype of your asian you must be
able to dance didn't exist you know what
i mean and i think it blew people's
minds when they watch that show season
one they're seeing
a modern um Asian faces Jabbawockeez we
take off our masks pretty much Asian
- KB who was probably more Asian than
all you know and people were just saying
yeah like these Asian people can dance
you know and so after you know we won
the show and then you know we're doing
all these interviews with all sorts of
publications a lot of Asian publications
we're hitting this up right and there's
a second how does it feel to finally you
know have Asians on the map you know and
kind of get recognized for you know
doing things that are kind of considered
to be these sort of like urban you know
artistic you know whatever and and it
was weird to us because we're like but
we've been doing this forever yeah I
mean we've been it's not like we just
decided yesterday to hey let's start
dancing and you get on TV
y'all remember [ __ ] Bionic that
[ __ ] was dope yo G man I
remember him [ __ ] battle of the year
dude I was like that's not a big boy but
he's [ __ ] killed it sick oh gee pop
Herman and yeah I think that was what
was interesting because we came off of
something not knowing how the world is
perceiving it and then it's somehow
developed this sort of positive
stereotype of like Asians can dance now
you know and then you know it's that
thing to like I feel that was the weird
thing especially moving out like kind of
going outside of Cali
I think we were very blessed to just
have been around so many different
cultures that could just do whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted so when people said
like oh you know like on YouTube
comments that we hear you know maybe the
way you speak or I speak and they're
like yo why are you talking like that
why you talkin buying California talks
yeah yeah but they live in a very small
world it's like they were either that
there's only a few Asians there or their
agents were just like the [ __ ] pencil
pushers and the [ __ ] number of cars
right so it's like oh those are the
Asians you you are the Asian stereotype
that everybody makes fun it right it
still exists but over here in California
specifically Sacramento it's not much of
those you know what I mean like
everybody just they are who they are
yeah and depending on whatever
neighborhood that you grew up and you
absorb that culture so when I went you
know whenever I heard people say like oh
man there's you know you're that
different Asian I'm like I'm not
and everybody's like this oh well I'm
from anyways so I didn't think I was
really neat right yeah it's funny cuz
you know you talk about the way that we
talk you know I saw I love people who
with accents right it's like oh my gosh
Australian accents yeah British accent
and you know when I would travel to
these places they're like oh my gosh I
love your accent I'm like we don't have
[Laughter]
like no you totally do and then even my
friend who she was Canadian you know and
then she's like I love like you have a
very specific accent I'm like what I
don't I don't know what you're talking
about you didn't but I guess it's
exactly like it it alright get naked
[Laughter]
crawl into my bed
and call me daddy how about that [ __ ]
there you go well you know it was great
having you in [ __ ] I wish I hope a lot
of this [ __ ] didn't get cut out dude it
was so [ __ ] good it's all good man I
knew it I [ __ ] up I knew I should have
switched out the [ __ ] car bail so
lazy and that's that's my fault
[ __ ] George you should have reminded
me about that you piece of [ __ ] good
George is gonna be editing this [ __ ] or
Bryce will [ __ ] you guys I love you guys
anyways guys you guys could check this
out and Spotify iTunes give us a five
star see us on all audio platforms leave
in the comments below who you wanted to
show what you guys wants to talk about
Ben plug your [ __ ] I'm on IG like
everybody else at B Tech B Tek
underscore Ben Chun B and CH ung follow
kynges at kynges ki NJ AZ we got a
podcast kynges podcasts cast with a k'
for some reason we spell everything that
has a C with the cake that's what nobody
could find you [ __ ] you spell
your [ __ ] we should be knowing this
spelling stuff but uh kyndra's calm yes
pretty much it we're on Twitter Facebook
if I don't people still use that stuff
but you know they do oh gee oh yes my
generation I'm still plugging away cool
yeah all right shall we see how the next
time